the world ready so it's been a little
while since I've talked about venom and
what's going on with that I don't know
if I talked about the fact that Tom
Hardy has been cast as Eddie Brock and
it is confirmed that it is Eddie Brock
it's not Flash Thompson it's not I can't
remember the the obvious I mean there
have been a number of Venom's there's
not any of the alternates it's not agent
venom it is Eddie Brock and also we have
director its ruben fleischer who made
Zombieland so thankfully Alex Kurtzman
who had been attached to it a long time
and the director of The Mummy he's not
on this so that's where we're starting
from and now there was a new nugget that
dropped in regards to what could be in
the movie and there was mention of
carnage now I want to first address the
way that most sites appear to be
reporting this most sites seem to be
saying carnage will be the villain in
venom the wording of the original
article which was in The Hollywood
Reporter said that there that the
villain carnage would be included now
lots of sites or whatever are choosing
to read that as carnage is the villain
of this movie the actual wording doesn't
say that explicitly who says it just
says the villain carnage will be
included that means that he's just going
to be there somewhere and acknowledging
the fact that he is a villain it does
not mean he is the villain of this film
and personally speaking I'm hoping that
he's not so before I get too far into
this I still want to reiterate I think
this idea of a standalone venom movie
that where we're not getting been
improperly introduced in a spider-man
movie first any idea of a hard-r horror
version of venom I don't think it's a
good idea but it's what they're doing so
if this is what it's going to be here I
do have some thoughts about the best way
to do this what I don't think is a great
idea because if we're going to get the
movie regardless I'd like to be the best
that it can possibly be so in my mind
there should not be a villain
in Maine real supervillain of the first
movie and my mind if you're going to do
it as a horror movie the horror should
be in the symbiotes it should be the it
should be the alien suit itself so the
horror should be what that thing is
capable of the horror should be how that
is affecting Eddie and by the end of the
movie he has more or less managed to
gain control over that and they begin
their symbiotic relationship I think the
film should be the struggle for control
between the two of them before they kind
of come to you know sort of a mutual
okay we're going to work together by the
very end and you set up carnage along
the way in there maybe you just set up
Cletus Kasady maybe you can have the the
spawn somebody would actually bond with
him in a post-credits sequence however
you want to do that but um depending on
where they pick up with Eddie because if
Eddie you know cletus's backstory is
that new serial killer he's doing time
he's sharing a cell with any so I mean
you can do with the connection that way
there's a million ways to introduce him
into the story but I do not think
carnage should be the villain in this
first movie because to establish the
suit to establish Eddie to establish
they're bonding together to have that
actually have meaning at the post adjust
and now we've got the suit Bob and and
just lose all possible impact of that
the focus really needs to be on him and
to try to integrate car engine on top of
that I I don't I think it's going to be
too much I don't think it's going to
work properly to have courage serve as
it alone in that first movie I think as
I said that first we should really if
spider-man is not appearing in this
which right now there's it's been it's
been brought up that it's possible he
might but right now it's unconfirmed
because that just stands Tom Hollands
contract does not include spin-offs that
is it accounts for his appearance in
Civil War and infinity war but and and
also two more sequels to spread around
homecoming but right now his
does not include this other stuff so
until it does we can't count on his
inclusion so right now we have to assume
that we can't guarantee that he'll be in
here so if you're going to make this
work focusing just on venom you really
need to put the focus there not
introduce the suit as quickly as
possible not slap it on them and I and
not have them go up and fight something
and if they put the focus on the
struggle of him gaining control of the
suit then that will bring more poignancy
to when carnage
yo Cletus becomes one with this the
carnage symbiote and becomes the
full-blown monster in your sequel
because then it's like the venom having
overcome and come to grips with this
power so that he's not an utter monster
has to deal with someone who did not
come to grips with it or at least is not
holding back the way that he is so you
get that that thing that comic books
saying how much movies like to do which
is the dark version of themselves this
what venom could have been then he has
to take that on but I do think you need
to have the first movie dedicated pretty
solely just to venom and make the whole
rooted in the Venom symbiote not in
whatever venom is going to be fighting
now those are my own thoughts on it I
and mainly a lot of this respond from
the fact that as I said people are
leaving to the conclusion that carnage
is the villain in this first venom movie
it's not necessarily the case I
personally hope that it isn't but if
you're going to try and build a
franchise out of that I'm really aside
from spider-man the one major character
to tie to him who does not necessarily
have to be tied back to spider-man is
carnage which to me again it makes it
all the more reason not to make him the
actual villain of this first move
because they need to basically just
burned off your one really notable
villain for this guide of piggies so
we'll see what we're going to get the
idea of carnage I'm most interested in
visually seeing how carnage is going to
come to life because I think it's going
to have to be a lot of CGI and whenever
something's a lot of CGI it can make me
both excited and nervous so something
that needs to be brought to life throw a
lot of CGI
I bring the possibility of getting
something really unique if they go in
and really put imagination into it or if
they don't put the proper money behind
it that it could just look really crappy
or if they don't put a lot of thought
into it they could end up doing
something that really could have been
done with practical effects so we'll see
what we end up with but I really like
the idea of cars visually just the suit
always in motion like in because it's
got that kind of black and red spot but
it's not it's not a pattern
it's just this sort of patchiness of the
black and the red so I want it I want
that to be shifting and gooping out in
the tendrils and they come back and they
do something I want I want constant Moo
I want constant jittery movement on this
thing because he can't stay still he's
too eager looking for the next thing
that he can kill so I'm excited to see
visually what we get with carnage again
I do hope we don't get them full-on
until a sequel and I may have to move up
finding and tracking down some of the
more recent cards appearances because my
main knowledge of the guy is from his
introduction in the 90s and maximum
carnage primarily and that's the main
thing I know him from I've had some
people recommend some of his more recent
stuff appearances to check out so maybe
I need to prioritize that before this
project gets too much further along so
carnage in the venom movie I think a lot
of us suspected this was going to happen
at some point but what are your thoughts
your hopes your fears on all this
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
available iTunes and stitcher I'm also
one half of the punch like a girl
podcast also available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]